so what about
uh ethereum which looks at
proof-of-stake and
a lot of different innovative ideas that
kind of
improve or seek to improve on some of
the flaws of bitcoin
ethereum another great idea so they
figured out if it was
that money and payments are important as
they are
they are only the first level the first
stepping stone
the next level are smart contracts and
they
were at the vision to say the people
will need
smart contract which allow me and you to
somehow
to transact securely without being shot
around by a trusted third party by a
mediator
by the way because mediators are hard to
find
and in fact maybe even impossible to
find if you live in thailand and i live
in um in
new zealand maybe we don't have a common
person that we know and trust
and even if we find them guess what they
want to be paid
so much so right that uh six percent of
the world uh
gdp is uh goes into financial friction
which is essentially third party
so the headed right to the world needed
that
but again the scalability
is not there and the system
is of smart contracts in ethereum is
slow
and expensive and and i believe
is not enough to satisfy the appetite
and the need we have
for smart contracts
you